the jazz republic performing arts
foundation the sponsors of this next
segment is doing their vegas thing
bringing a new community bringing the
community a new jazz festival for the
entire family to enjoy check it out
[Music]
it's a movement where jazz has no
borders and that's what you call a
crossover thing it's not thing it's bang
that's right thank you because in our
and what we write is it is crossover
music where it's not jazz in the
traditional sense i mean there are
traditional elements to it but um
but yeah it kind of goes into pop and
some hip-hop flavors and things like
that an album that led world-renowned
trumpeter bijan watson and critically
acclaimed singer-songwriter niles thomas
to a 2022 grammy nomination how do you
guys feel about that
well i mean
it's about time maybe
you know timing is everything and
we've worked together so long
on other projects and
coming together
for this in las vegas i guess
city of dreams other projects like their
jazz republic foundation concert series
radio show and the jazz republic music
festival and that's what you call
a co-founder thing it's important to
make sure that in the arts community
that we're always encouraging young
artists to
create original music
um and so that's kind of
or wouldn't you say our primary exactly
you can't follow that one he said it all
he said all but niles speaking of
original music you know this separates
your festival from other jazz festivals
right why is that
because of that reason alone i mean
everything that we do as bijan was
mentioning even with the when we started
the concert series at smith center back
in 17
so we do those quarterly
um because because we write original
music we thought well we need to do that
with everything we do so that all the
artists that we invite need to do the
same thing because there is a lot of
artists that do tribute work or you have
the sinatra look-alikes and the this and
the that and that's cool yeah and it's
cool it's cool it's super cool it's just
not what we do so and we also want to uh
what we what we tell peoples we welcome
everyone to our music table you know so
what's on the music table september 17th
at the springs preserve amphitheater
here's a sneak peek at the festival
lineup one of our headliners is gerald
clayton and then vocalist renee marie
stefan harris vibraphonist with his
group blackout which is amazing local
now uh ignacio barrow uh
drummer percussionist uh he's bringing
his trio uh spencer day and then we have
a few student groups that we're going to
be inviting to perform you know from
some of the local local schools we're
going to be performing uh to kick the
day off and
we got a couple surprises also on the
table it's going to be a full day of
amazing
food we've got some great vendors are
going to be involved
some great signature drinks
uh
virgin and
alcoholic we will have we got because we
want because we want families that's
right we want families and you will be
able to bring you know uh your you know
little baskets and
so on picnic type fare uh
the springs preserve amphitheater if
you're familiar with is a great place to
see a show there's not a bad seat in the
house even and we will have reserve
seating as well as lawn seating so it's
a good combination and everyone should
have a great sight line and it's going
to be a lot of fun a great sight line to
see these two grammy-nominated artists
do their thing with their gang as the
method men
thank you to the jazz republic
performing arts foundation for
sponsoring this segment catch the jazz
republic music festival september 17th
at the springs preserve amphitheater
from 1 to 10 p.m a full day of fun for
more details and tickets just head to
jazzrepublicmusicfest.com
all right